on this week's show can you buy a
three-bed hey check out in the news how
will a new prime minister affect
property investing and we're gonna be
answering all your property related
questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends
Iowa slade's I'm Alistair Cunningham now
and welcome to this week's property
investors podcast we've got so much
going on right now it's so busy
it's just absolutely like insect-like we
could literally we could do a mod cast
just talking about what we've been up to
this week what we obviously both move in
house will save will save that I saw
that when we did the Facebook live you
you positioned your Porsche keys oh
there she is
the Porsche is here that's he is Porsche
by the way I'm gonna have to retract my
earlier statement because when I was it
when I was picking it up I told them I
told them that we had a discussion about
this on our podcast I said Russell says
Porsche I say it's Porsche and the guy
went yes Porsche yeah because we get it
drummed into us at the factory whenever
they go to the factory every morning
they do like a thing with the oldest the
other I think they say and it's Porsche
they get drummed into its Porsche
Porsche Porsche yeah I said I said this
morning this was it was yesterday car
over I rang him I said I'm actually seen
it yet no we've been together but we've
been in London and you only drive in
London no an octa miles away and I was
oh yes to take me out after work today
after we finished podcast you have to
give me a ride and he was like yeah yeah
I was like translation can you give me a
lift home yeah so yeah that's very so
what have you been up we were running an
event one way yeah we were running rent
revolution so it's like a four-hour
Academy members free event it was
awesome wasn't it it was phenomenal
really was phenomenal even if we do say
so much yeah was we come off the back of
there was a DfE and then we had
DfE was money to where it was an
embedded crash course I've not been
around cuz I went to my answer I got
back from Miami on the Thursday mit
straights the crash course that was that
was on the a Thursday night Friday
Saturday Monday Tuesday Wednesday I was
at DFA yeah then I went on holiday yeah
cut that short to come back for round
two
the last month I've just been like you
know I haven't been just traveling we
had the DfE then we had a crash course
and I went straight down London for the
four days rent to rent revolution and
launchpad and it was what was awesome
it's awesome rental revolution finished
on Saturdays I don't know which which I
mean we are now Monday yeah talking 2
days right now and they've already been
people they've gotten got deals over the
weekend there's people that have got
deals I've collect and the keys this
week I know at least two people yeah
literally we have the whole room we've
taught them how to get the deal yeah we
were getting people getting deals I mean
almost had to go and view the property
yes but getting deals in principle there
was about 15 20 deals yeah over the
phone in principle it was just a manic
manic weekend we talk all the time don't
we about implementation about how you
can lay on everything yeah and they show
actually up and do it
it's pointless you just learn yeah and
they were I think there was a lot of
serious action takers in that room yeah
and it's proved proofs in the pudding
they've gone out they've secured deals
that Clayton the keys this week and I
know everyone there was a mighty energy
in the room is amazing anyway that's
what we've been up to this week
so on this week's show three beds HMOs
do they work and all that some people
meet them work but I think I think it
depends where it is and I think in
general I would say no but I know there
is some people make him work see on the
eviction the first two challenges one of
those was a three-bet HMO yeah yeah no
your one was that your one was a
four-mile were the one I'd was it was
that one and was that profitable yeah
the thing is the reason when I'm saying
it doesn't it it might not work as well
is because if you have a void if you
have an extended void peared so if it's
in an area where there's very few voids
ie like the property if it fills up it
gets if it if it becomes void it gets
filled up very quickly then I wouldn't
see as much of a
but I don't know if your voice every
that to see you know what I mean I mean
yeah I know that but what I mean is if
you've got a four bed you have one void
you've still got three rooms payin rent
if you have a single it you have one
void you got no rooms yeah but we're not
talking single guys we're talking hate
your mores single let's hit two more is
different different you're talking to
different clientele different different
customer base completely and like
certainly we've always timeless always
said to be two rooms pay the bills and
the rents and mortgages and in the other
two rooms are profit so if you've only
got three rooms and you have one void
you're not making much money later on
you whereas if you've got four rooms in
one void you still got that extra room
paying your money so I think it could it
can obviously can work because I know
people are doing it I just think you've
got be a lot more careful about where
you're buying it where you're buying and
what areas like for instance if you're
in the south I know I know several
people have got like three or four
bedroom houses I just written at three
bedrooms but the rent in the rooms out
is 70 hundred pound and that's that's
plainly money but where you're getting
cheaper ranges where I'd be worried
about okay well let's look let's look at
how to rose and we'll try and work it
out and see what we think uncle will
come up with a conclusion for the end of
the day so first of all the three better
HMOs work I suppose the first thing you
got to ask is a three-bed a
three-bedroom house yeah would of course
work yes okay a three-bedroom house yeah
would be a four bet HMO yeah why not as
long as it's got adequate caminos and
space it has that to research all right
so what do we need for a three bed hit
you more no for just so people we're all
on the same page what do you need for a
HMO first of all you've got the minimum
room sizes minimum room sizes seventy
square metres please make these rooms
honestly I hate the standards today so
miss Graham is literally bigger than my
room little palaces thicker than 70
square feet and it has to have obviously
a communal if the rooms aren't under 100
square feet so you need Jamie our
building that's got two reception rooms
or our massive kitchen Diana where you
can have you know like a really extended
kitchen diner where you can have half of
it as communal half as kitchen so
but like for instance um so technically
if you had a three-bed h'mong yeah could
technically be a to bad house yeah it
could be yeah so we've cheaper to buy
Wow much cheaper to rent if you do not
rent to rent absolutely you could
absolutely yeah as well as long as the
number you've got to look at every deal
deal deal at a time you can't you can't
just see as a blanket it does not work
right it won't work but I think if
you're gonna do you've got to be super
super careful numbers stack up and it's
in a prop an area where they probably
has good rental demand like really good
rental demand because for instance if
you've done it in Hull I would say no
because the rooms are a little bit
slower to rent out in house so you could
avoid period longer and I don't know but
isn't it isn't it in a way isn't easy to
rent out that a for bed to drink or fill
three rooms not for so as long as all
you're doing is written at one room and
yeah you're not renting out the whole
house are you so hm or you're looking to
rent one room at a time
yeah that's what I'm saying but surely
that's easier them because you only got
it three times so it's like 25% easier
yeah I mean the fact if it's a three
bedroom the remote will be everything
but let me just point something else as
well so you said let's say check the
area's gotta be really good because I
might have voids but let's say you
picked an area with a four bed and you
get the same area of a three bed it was
just as bad if the three bed you only
feel to two rooms yeah
wouldn't the four bed when you feel two
rooms as well because yeah yes but what
I mean in general okay I know what
you're saying I know but you're coming
out you still wouldn't have a void
period but like for instance I've got
like we've got a friend who an Academy
member who lives in Dagenham and he
lives in an HMO
he literally one of his 1d one of the
people moved out the same day the next
person moved in and that happens all the
time yeah
whereas so I three bed would be you'd
have less you may still have the same
void periods but you would have less
void periods because you got less rooms
potentially so it just makes it easier
what I'm getting at is I I personally
would be more comfortable with a for bed
and if they're in the south it's
different 3 bed might work Evers in the
nor listen you don't make
any sense you know I know in my hair
damage not getting crazy well that's
kind of key to this it's not the
workings of other stairs mind
it's the cogs are clocking and at the
end of the day the look look just simple
right right
you have two houses on a straight yeah
right one of them is a four-bed yeah
one's a three-bet Yeah right you decide
to buy the for bed cuz it's safer yeah I
see the same straight because you're
worried you'd buy the three beds you
might only fill two rooms yeah but you
may only sell filters and voice yes but
my point being is you've got more
opportunity in the for bed to make money
now and you know well I think you're
actually point is but you're not saying
it it's the bills and it's there no go
on what do you think I think your point
is because it depends on the ROI right
course so before bed you've got you've
got a chance to make extra money out no
make sense out more bedrooms right yeah
then you've got a look at the return on
investment if you return investment was
good for the three I don't see it as
more of a risk than a four because as
long as you're gonna fill the rooms but
you never buy a four thinking well I may
want to fill three rooms anyway you want
to fill them all anyway right so it
doesn't but the difference is you have
and from someone who's managed by a lot
of HMOs yeah
there's certain rooms so that are
difficult to fill mhm right so like Joe
smaller rooms look at this morning so
when when you've got a for bed you might
have three double rooms and one but fill
like that and one boxing that's a bit of
a nightmare if you had a three bed that
had a box room does a bit of a nightmare
you might be screwed is that your point
my point is yes that and also that with
four beds we've all we've always said
that two rooms pays all the bills peas
or peas all your costs and then you've
got two rooms profit so if you think
that that that sort of theory - a 3 bed
2 rooms pay your bills and then you
wouldn't got one room making the profit
but that is a rule of thumb the a noise
and generally the bills are not going to
differ that much for an extra bedroom
not that much make them make one a
little bit
no but the purchase price may not be
that much different either so like for
instance in hold you can buy a two bed
in the same street as a three bed for
like not much less
enough folks why would you go for a
smaller property and to me it's about
risk I know you I know if you've got a
four-bed not an hour for bed and a
three-bed hit him on the same street and
only you've still wouldn't got two rooms
for that's fine but you haven't you
haven't got the opportunity to fill four
rooms in this you want oh god until 3:00
so I don't think you'll ever make as
much money even if there are why is
right even if it all were still 20%
you're still never gonna make as much
cash flow in this one obviously you're
not because I just don't think it one
that's why I'm not and I wouldn't person
endure three bed and lay sits in long
but surely surely it just depends on the
on the individual listen of course more
rooms are better hmm
alright always because explain so let's
just see and this is not specific to
again this is Majed it's right but in
its gonna sound daft I don't care right
so were we values if you if you've got a
three bed three bed and a for bed right
yeah and let's just see that third pin
in okay right so you have four tenants
in one property three tenets and one
property yeah we're all listen right
yeah for tears in one for three tents
are yeah and you get one tenant visa to
come is a complete no bed right stop
spins around all sorts you've still got
three tenants in this place paying the
rent whereas in this one you've only got
to do you mean so I I just like that ace
with him in but but that is that is a
good thing and a bad thing because
what's easier what's better a single
there or a HMO but we're not talking
about extremes what's better was it was
easier easier single that every day of
the week
well because why because you've got
that's what that's why this house almost
hit Lester's tenants yeah
so why suddenly he's a former better
than three because you've got litters
you got the advantages of age where we
got less tenants I get that but then if
you will with free bed why not will
single it good single it because you
make more money not much more but time
you peel the bills you probably make
that if you're not then then there's no
good but the one thing about right they
should see by the way just to be clear
yeah I don't realize three beds no no
you don't but so for that okay for bed
hate you more water and like
Wolverhampton and make about 1500 we get
about 350 380
maybe I think one of the rooms gets 420
whatever right
so if you see they should say ballpark
figure the average room rent is 350 quid
in the midland year so 350 times three
fifty seven fifty and i seven hundred
and are three hundred thousand and fifty
okay so a thousand and fifty and a
three-bed you drop one ten off there
because he's easy starts not paying his
rent aware but you're down sorry if I
wasn't fifty you drop the bills off so
what would your typical bill was an hour
three bed hitchmo be my form to quit
five and equip I think a mortgage
council tax what's that's so depends on
anyways but by oh by a rule of thumb we
sort of see forty forty five percent
yeah so let's just drop this is see it's
five hundred quid you won't live for
five hundred then you but if you but you
get a good single late you could be late
for five hundred that's what I'm getting
out so if you're gonna go three bid why
not just go big single it like a decent
single line and all again all the pins
or give it is how it's not a blanket
there's not a blanket ruling for this it
so it's a case by case and it's a case
of Liz let's look at every single one
has the cotton because I think I think
made some good points I think make some
good points so badly
but I think you might think maybe you
can do subtitles Scottish subtitles
translate the the bumbling zuv of
Alastair basically in a nutshell I think
three bed hitting was a canister in
London so in London I think I'll do them
in London because the room rates are far
higher and you like far higher a lot
somewhere that Oxford them where you can
get really good room rate rumery talks
with Cambridge like so for instance I've
bring back I come back to this house in
Dagenham they're getting the eight
hundred pound a room and there's the
property is not when we were looking in
Cambridge it was like 850 room yeah well
we were shocked we were shocked how high
it was but this is my point now right
it's all about return on investments all
your other points I understand what
you're saying but I think a three-bed
works if it's in the right air
ya know it's a little bit more difficult
to make working in cheaper areas yeah I
think if it's in the right area and if
you get the right house yeah I think
need to make sure you got all rooms are
good but to be honest I kind of think
that with four beds because it's it's
very easy to say uh if you've got a box
room it doesn't really matter but that's
not a very good house is it no it's not
you don't want a house that he's going
to rent one of the rooms so you want to
get a house that all the rooms right out
anyway do you know I was in a chair more
like two weeks ago it was a I was
dropped I picked a friend up from there
who lives in a hate Jamal and he showed
me his room and it's like huge and that
every single room in his house was like
this it was probably about 140 square
meters square feet it was humongous his
double bed was in the corner and it's
like he's still got like like he's so
much written and if this was a it was
warm still and in London yeah in London
it was war from store and this is a 6
bed property in every rooms that size
and they've all got like a little
ensuite in the corner and everything
everything he pees I bet he pays north
of it better but one - no no no no and
he they're all that they're all that
size they're about but the biggest room
in a property's a thousand and fifty
pound a month and he pees eight ninety
so do you not mean he's pain like top
wafer ensuite you know that's not bad
though in London wow I didn't think so
for an ensuite and
but the rooms huge honestly it's like
100 and 450 square meters square feet
it's Quinn Neos square feet with ensuite
and and they are but if you imagine if
that that probably wouldn't have been
that much to buy like it would be more
than in Hull would be probably couple
hundred grand 250 grand but if you've
got six rooms bringing in 800 quid us
that's a that's a chunk yeah it's a wage
interest you know certainly there's a
lot of profit we made there that's why I
can that's why this there is a lot of
investors that just will not buy outside
their areas because they make their cash
like they make really good returns yeah
and they don't get the best sort of em
so in summary then three bit HMO it does
work but it's more difficult to work
you've got to
right areas yeah would we go with that
I've accepted the person in Stoke was
getting about 20 percent ROI yeah in
Stoke with a 3-bit HMO student student
accommodation because it's just a too
bad house they got if it's so cheap it
depends some yeah again it depends I
mean he probably install and he bought
it ten years ago wherever he probably
paid like 30 grand for mean if we bought
it off him now that was that we were
looking at buying it we still would have
got a 20% over okay three baby was in
Stoke so it can't work so the other
alternative I supposed to be if you can
buy the house very very cheaply yeah
well if you get on this options and
things that are if you get one lease
options and the lease payments are quite
long then so I hope it's what what this
is clearly cleared it up completely I'm
sure that everyone now has got a clear
image in their mind of exactly whether a
3-bit works also I'm glad that we've
managed to 100% laid out clarify I feel
ready to move on it's now time for this
[Music]
okay so in the news well there's been
one thing that's been in my Facebook
feed news recently yeah quite a lot and
it's what about Boris Johnson who's
Boris Johnson oh you know the rock yeah
yeah his cousin it's hair doing
Johnson's work now doings that it's
funny into because if although he did
make a statement that it was and did he
yeah everyone's got an opinion about
everyone like he's got his lovers and
he's got heaters and tea well I was
talking about this I was talking like
this at DFA yeah we did a few weeks ago
I think we was actually the day that he
came in yeah well I was scrolling
through my Facebook feed
and all it was was oh no Boise has come
in our brexit
a night and for me just annoying it just
annoys me that the negativity because
listen I'm openly will admit that I
don't follow politics particularly and
give all all the new cool give a rip
about politics and the reason I don't is
because I believe art you know the news
and all that crap is just this so much
and I don't want that negativity in my
life
angry we you know I was I say the entire
watch the news went went went male
salmon Iran it would if you're on it
okay yeah last week but you didn't you
know yeah I was on the radio all the
week I would have listened if I'd known
what were you want BBC Radio Northampton
we talking about just property and like
what I've done
really you tell me I don't like the
broadcast but you're on the you are
broadcasting you doing no but I was
right is the definition of broadcast
yeah it's just I've been in a few times
I went on there when I was women come
back from Uganda and I've been invited
do you not been invited to speak at loss
of radio stations in London no after my
talk I gave it the crash course well
yeah I set one of them up if you
remember I didn't know about that one
okay the so then someone else said
I want you on the shelves I haven't got
time but you got my crappy podcast part
yeah yeah yeah I remember you got
invited to speak at an event and you're
like him mmm I think it was like 10
people they knew like yeah yeah sounds
awesome
I'm busy that deep I can say in somebody
there I knew like hey man I've got you
come up to me cuz I hate Elst I've got
this really amazing about yeah he goes
I've got this really amazing event for
you to go and speak at and he goes I
can't make it but he goes I'd love if
you would go there and represent me you
represent me you're upsetting for me I
do he goes please go there and I get
there and there's like 20 people there
that's right every time he's one of
those people right he told me it's like
first time he tells us every time he
tells the story
till you eventually get to the truth
no in vienna's but after the talker done
it a crash-course a few weeks back I add
like loads of people ask me - how many
three three yeah no listen listen let's
say listen one of them is you own the
media company and he's like very high up
and he's got links to all the radio
stations and stuff and he wants me to go
and talk about various subjects and then
I had a lady stand up and she runs a
radio station in South East London she
wants me to go and talk on there how did
we get to this media and about you said
about being if we're not yes yes so so
meet me personally I I don't I don't
watch the news if you watched it's just
all negative and you never seem
positively I'd rather read a book yeah
or listen to listen to an audiobook then
listen to the news and get because I'm a
big believer in your environment and you
want positive environment and make it
just you know when you're on Facebook in
the worst his face but when you see like
those videos of like horrible things
it's all look at this he should be post
that holiday like somebody post a lot of
like people being really cruel to
animals and do that why would they post
that [ __ ] well do not on their little
tip for you on there's a
a button you can press I haven't do it
for a while because I did ages ago
dammit you can sort of like press the
button you can say I do not want to see
content like this mmm and it blocks it I
don't want it gives me a bad day kiss me
but do you see I'm uh
and sometimes it happens to me and this
annoys me when you're looking at sports
news yeah and you're reading because I
do like the football and I'm reading
down the page and then there's some
adverts for other news stories yeah just
the advert it's like you know I'm like
oh man so back to Boris that's a boy yes
basically I don't like the news I don't
like I don't like politics
I believe you like him from what I've
seen of him yeah yeah I think he's a bit
of a bumbling idiot but from what in a
way but that's his persona yeah do I
like it my like I like some of his
policies so he goes with me so one of
the things he's planning on doing is
scrapping stamp duty cool for any house
under five hundred thousand pound so as
property investors you lot should all be
loving that I think I think he's gonna
be great property investors I think it's
gonna be great he's very big into
building lots of new homes
yes right really come on let's just ask
this really how crucial is that who if
we like the Prime Minister or not
because he cannot single-handedly pass
anything through the comments well no
it's not it's not like we're under a
dictatorship of course we're not so
whatever he puts forward has to go
through Westminster it has to be
approved in a has to be voted against so
it doesn't matter if it's Boris Johnson
or Russell weeds it doesn't matter well
that would be pretty cool well doesn't
matter it don't matter dessert because
it's got to all go through Westminster I
think no listening to our posters of
speech of his I watched it on on
Facebook about some of this like did you
know that there was more hat more houses
built it was over this year or last year
more houses built than in any year for
the last 30 30 years I didn't know I
think for property investors I think and
and you know who would I think would be
Jeremy Corbyn do you not want Jeremy
Corbyn to get in but why not
Joe I don't actually I don't follow
politics I've got no interest in them
I'm not mad
like this but I couldn't give a rip it
does not affect my life doesn't come is
the thing right I think Morris will make
it a bit easier for us I think Jeremy
Corbyn make it a bit harder but I think
either way you'd be able to invest in
profit or successful people will be
successful and don't matter who's in
power yeah I brought people will find a
reason to win jab at the pet and they'll
blame the person in power for their
brokenness you know and they're like
lack of success because it's the prime
minister or the government you know take
responsibility it's your your life
you'll be responsible don't care who's
in power no I'm not I'm not - Bobby's a
real not to bother to pick Donald Trump
off I get him in pill
ouch that's gonna be controversial right
now on the on the I don't care Donald
Trump he'd be brewing on the run this
country's done for America
Oh some thumbs down at that comment I
believe it's not a popular opinions I
probably never who cares yeah it's my
opinion I'm entitled to it yeah great
but I think Boris is gonna be is gonna
be good for property investors be traced
and does them like of this does Donald
Trump like Boris Johnson yeah yeah yeah
well I mean Donald Trump is it's got a
funny way of going about stuff sometimes
but you can't argue with some of the
results no you can't so you can't give
you that but yet but more importantly I
think it's about focusing on unlikely
what you said focusing on you focusing
on the stuff that you can control see
the thing is if I could get all bothered
about politics and I could research it
and look into it and and what would it
really change do you know it's like him
I was in London a few weeks back and
there was all these people don't know
Marcin and they were protesting I can't
even move it wasn't about Paul what a
waste of time what a waste of their day
cuz did they really think honestly it
was out so it was on Parliament Square I
don't even know what the I don't know if
it was about who's in charge I don't
know but there was like 45 of them just
standing here with a placards corner and
I drove past thinking you Saddles come
on man like you stood there all day
doing absolutely nothing do they really
think the person's going to go you've
protested
let's just change that for you yeah come
on no I do think I do think there's
certain so can i sir I could do that if
I was really passionate about something
well maybe not for you but for me if I
was really passionate about something
and it was coming in and I believe this
is the rule this is wait this is there
all you gotta do I take right do it so
something happens do I like it yes or no
right if you don't like it if you'd like
it then great focus on it well I'll be
positive you don't know yeah then you've
got a thing okay
can I change it yes or no if I can't
change it I'm not gonna wind about it
I'm not gonna moan about it I'm gonna
get on with it and just ignore it and
focus on the stuff I can't change like
everything else in my life yes right if
I can't change it
then I'll go think okay how how bothered
am i yeah okay you could put a lot of
work see people moaning about Boris I'm
not are you gonna run for MP then yeah
would you differently yeah oh you're not
okay
well then stop cause the truth is right
is that unless you're really in the know
we don't know all the ins and outs the
media control what they want us to think
anyway you know like you know there's
always always got an agenda they've
always got there and they're just gonna
they're gonna feed that and that's what
them everyone thinks and then everyone's
you don't know the you don't know it's
like the dude it's a football match
screaming and shouting at the football
manager telling them how it run the
football game and it's like did you set
up there like with a belly right there
yeah and like come on man you're set up
there and you're telling him how to run
the football match like so rule of thumb
is the rule if you can't change it don't
moan about it yeah if you can't change
it then decide is it worth anything is
then do something if it's not but you
certainly don't don't know about it no I
agree I completely agree with that and I
think Boris will be good for property
investors so there's the good news right
it's now time for this
[Music]
okay so welcome to the questions and
answers part if you want to leave us a
question you can have a comment on our
YouTube videos or if you join the
property investors with Samuel Leeds
Facebook group we do a Facebook live
normally just before we film any show
you get the opportunity to leave some
questions on there so make sure you join
that group okay
so first question from Leoben Ahmed will
article for have an impact on rent to
HMOs well yeah because if you're running
it as a hmm no you can't do it in
article 4 area and let's it's already
being it's already been it depends if
you're looking for if you're looking for
like a rent to rent which is a single
layer which you will then convert into H
more than Y absolutely if it's an up and
running hate you more then you wouldn't
you wouldn't have to be too concerned
about that because you'll have Graham
Paulo writes dear but you'll still have
to be aware of article 4 yeah so yes
great question eat well thank you okay
I've got one here and this is from PW I
don't know you want but PW that search
for initials Parrish power woo yeah a
question regarding deal source and what
checklist or point plan do you use to
check whether probably a suitable to put
forward to investors and so whenever we
do are go out interviewing we have our
like a 12 page view and inspection form
that we fill out it just covers they
details every room room sizes
measurements measurements of doors
measurements of like everything
basically where the radio is our where
the powerpoints powerpoints are the
windows condition of this condition of
that condition of the roof type of
boiler any sort of dates and the boiler
any dates on the electrical boxes it's
just it's like a 12-page document and it
just goes through every single room
clearly lays out the condition all that
sort of stuff so we use that so just
perhaps create something put something
together and use that when you go and
try and pass that on to an investor so
hope that helps okay I've got a question
for Alastair from the road to financial
freedom the question is just one word
actually it's just okay nice so I
believe he's talking to you he is
talking to me
so rule to financial freedom good luck
okay you know as a review ever noticed
but Alastair can't say okay he says okay
okay right and he does this quite a lot
on on stage and I
The Macallan for it somebody's eye we
talked about this last week didn't we
tell the same stories told before so I
won't bother but basically someone was
saying okay I thought was for me he
didn't I was not offended with any
question on the Facebook live can't go
on Facebook brings a question Oh should
we just call this did I go on which dude
that did there yeah okay we got a
question from James actually is a
question as well has it ever occurred to
you guys that you're a parasite thanks
James has it ever occurred to you to
know the difference between singular and
plural that's a good idea
maybe you're as thick as you sound has
ever occurred to you guys that you man
listen it makes sense why would you go
to the effort of calling somebody that
like if you've got nothing better to do
your life get a life actually care care
it doesn't affect us in any way shape or
all form me right okay how it's from
abraham sia side how do you develop a
relationship with the state agents
specifically for rent to rent how would
you go about approaching them and what
would you say to them I'd say how are
you doing how you doing yeah okay listen
relationships were state agents are
quite easy they're very easy and you're
dealing with people and how you doing
work you're dealing with people at the
end all day so I would always wench
you've got your area where you're
walking I would always go in to see them
don't phone them up because they get
hundreds of phone calls weekly from
people picking the brains I would
literally get on get on the ground the
you will [ __ ] yeah
I'd follow him initially to make an
appointment but not the a simple keep
further you play a bit hard to get no I
wouldn't
can we be serious for like one minute oh
right just get in there go on sit in
front of them meet them be nice then I'm
sure you're a nice person and I'm sure
that will come across relationships come
to how do you do it then just fight
struggle I get something else to do it
for me okay I send somebody in and but
just get in there
them treat their time with the same
respect you and your time treated us so
that I always say this if you're if
you're bill to go to a viewing at nine
o'clock and they did their nine o'clock
and you arrive late that's a very bad
star or always be on time because that
estate agent might have ten fifteen
viewings that day and if you delay by
fifty minutes cuz you can't get there on
time well never that they lit most they
leave done after fifteen minutes I don't
know but my point being is just do what
you say you're gonna do with them if you
say you're gonna get there get there if
you say you're gonna go to the office go
to the office and and I always find that
the but you're the best way the best
ways is to do business with them do
business but do it you become a client
of theirs yeah you know and you start
actually you know you use them as he's
why this is why Alastair is the man
again in Reverse that agent yeah deal
sorcerer so he's using them all the time
and let me tell someone right if you're
a deal source and you're looking to get
M estate agents and you tell them you're
gonna buy a deal off them and you're
gonna pass it on invest and you don't
buy it pass it to an investor because
you haven't got any investors or you
can't sell it that you'll ruin that
relationship for that estate agent I
would recommend even if you're a deal
sorcerer and you've got a deal from an
investor that you're gonna pass an
investor even if you can't sell it for
money give it away because it keeps a
relationship with the invest but their
estate agent you can even do that for
your first couple to build a
relationship with your stage yeah I'm
with investors we've killed plates
before me yeah yeah very but yeah right
but it well guys thanks ever so much for
tuning in I hope you enjoyed this week's
show we'll be back next Saturday at 7
p.m. we will see you there
[Applause]
Oh